the MP met Hancock going into I'm a
celebrity get me out of here joining me
now from Westminster Sky political
correspondent Tamara Cohen and tomorrow
it's not the first time a politician has
done this uh is it but there has
certainly been quite a lot of Fallout
already
absolutely we've confirmed that Matt
Hancock the former Health secretary is
to appear on I'm a celebrity which
begins filming in Australia this weekend
and airs on ITV from Sunday he of course
was Health secretary during the pandemic
then had to resign over an affair with a
colleague and pictures of that during
the lockdown he is now a back bencher
and has decided to appear on the show
alongside other stars Like a Boy George
and the rugby player Mike Tindall we've
heard from a political Ally of Matt
Hancock about his decision to appear on
the show he told us that it's the most
watched show on ITV and it's an
incredible opportunity for him to engage
with 12 million britons who tune in
every night this Ally went on Matt has
always believed in communicating
directly with the people he represents
whether that's pounding the streets in
West Suffolk that's his constituency
where this Ally says that at will be
supporting constituents who need help
with anything and they say politicians
like Matt must go where the people are
it's also transpired that he was
approached about it a little while ago
but decided not to go because of the
political turmoil but he now feels that
Richie sunac has a firm hand on what's
going on in government now of course the
controversy here is that he would be
going while Parliament is sitting and he
has already had the whip suspended we've
heard from the chief whip of the
conservative party Simon Hart and this
is what he told us
following a conversation with Matt
Hancock I have considered the situation
and believe this is a matter serious
enough to Warrant suspension of the whip
with immediate effect so despite Matt
Hancock's protestations that he will
still via his constituency office be
supporting local people looks like the
whip has been suspended for the duration
that he is there and depending on how
long he is able to stay in the
competition he may miss quite a bit of
time in Parliament of course he's not
the first MP to appear on a on this show
or indeed other reality TV shows Nadine
Doris who was until recently in the
cabinet appeared on I'm a celebrity some
years ago and also had the whip
withdrawn and we've also seen former
politicians going on these Strictly Come
Dancing show including Ed Balls and Anne
woodicum so he joins a long list of
those some with mixed success